Here you see MIT's Walter Lewin, about to
swing on a pendulum. We can write a function
for how the angle theta 1 depends on time,
which completely describes his motion.
But what if Walter were to start swinging
from here, instead of there? We'd need a different
function, theta 2.
And what if one of his students were to give
him a little push? That's right—we'd need
a third function, theta 3.
It would be great if we could write a single
rule, based on physical principles, that governs
the behavior of the pendulum. And every function
that describes pendulum motion would have
to satisfy this rule.
This video will show you how to write rules
like these using the language of differential
equations.
This video is part of the Differential Equations
video series. Laws that govern a system's
properties can be modeled using differential
equations.
Hi, my name is Peter Dourmashkin. And I am
a senior physics lecturer at MIT.
Differential equations are very important
in modeling physical phenomena. They describe
rules that constrain the behavior of many
complex physical and social systems.
Before watching this video, you should be
familiar with drawing free body force diagrams
and applying Newton's second law in polar
coordinates. You should remember how to write
a Taylor series expansion of a function about
a point, and understand what it means.
After watching this video, you should be able
to do the following 3 things:
Understand that the physical laws governing
a system's properties can be modeled using
differential equations,
Explain that the solution to a differential
equation is a family of functions,
And recognize that specifying initial conditions
determines a particular solution function
to a differential equation.
Let's see how differential equations arise
as a natural language to model the pendulum.
To develop this model, we will use our knowledge
of physics.
First, what is a pendulum? A pendulum is typically
an object, called a bob, which hangs from
one end of a string. The other end is fixed
to a pivot point.
Let's pause the video. Try to describe what
you think are the important properties of
pendulum motion.
You might have said that
the behavior is periodic, that the same motion
repeats over and over. We say that the pendulum
exhibits oscillations, or harmonic motion.
Maybe you also noted that the motion is rotational,
moving in a circular path about the pivot
point.
Finally, you may know that the motion eventually
stops, that is, the oscillations experience
a damping force. Overall we describe the motion
as "damped harmonic motion."
Now, let's develop a model for the pendulum.
A good first step is to choose a coordinate
system. Because the pendulum rotates about
a fixed pivot point, it makes sense to use
polar coordinates. Theta is the angle the
bob makes with the vertical, and r is the
distance of the bob from the pivot point.
Remember that when using vector in polar coordinates,
r-hat is the unit vector that points radially
outward from the pivot point, and theta-hat
is the unit vector that points perpendicular
to r-hat, tangential to the motion of the
pendulum.
Whenever you model a system, it's important
to recognize that you are making some simplifying
assumptions. We are going to start by making
three:
1.
The string has no mass.
2. The mass, m, of the bob is uniformly distributed.
3.
The string has length L and does not stretch
or shrink.
This means that all motion happens in the
tangential direction; none in the radial direction.
Now let's figure out what we need to know
to describe the motion of the pendulum.
At the speeds we are dealing with, we can
ignore relativistic effects; there are no
electromagnetic forces, and the scale is large
enough that quantum mechanics isn't necessary.
So we'll use Newton's second law to describe
the motion of the pendulum.
What forces do you think we need to consider
in this problem?
Let's draw a free body diagram for an instant
where the bob is to the right of vertical,
and moving downwards.
There is the gravitational force acting on
the bob, due to the interaction between the
Earth and the bob, which points straight down
with magnitude mg. We treat this force as
acting on the center of mass of the bob.
The string exerts a force on the bob, which
you know as tension. We don't know what the
magnitude of this force is, so we'll just
write it as T, pointing inwards towards the
pivot point.
Finally, the motion will eventually stop,
so there must be damping forces acting on
the system. The damping forces are complicated.
For example, there is friction at the pivot
point, and air resistance on the bob. Let's
make an assumption that the damping force
due to friction at the pivot point is negligible
because the string is small and lubricated.
Then the damping force is almost entirely
from the drag due to air resistance.
The bob doesn't experience any drag when it
is stationary, and experiences larger amounts
of drag the faster it is moving. Because the
speeds of the pendulum are relatively slow,
that is we do not expect there to be turbulence,
we can model the drag force as being linearly
proportional to velocity, and opposing the
direction of motion. Because we assume that
all motion occurs in tangential direction,
we can draw the damping force like so.
Recall that Newton's second law is a vector
equation. Because force and acceleration are
both vector quantities, we need to decompose
them into r-hat and theta-hat components.
Remember, acceleration can be decomposed into
two component vectors, one pointing radially
inward called centripetal acceleration, and
a tangential component vector called angular
acceleration. We also need to decompose our
force vectors. Notice that the tension force
is already pointing radially inward, in the
negative r-hat direction. And the damping
force is pointing in the positive theta-hat direction,
opposite the direction of the angular velocity
vector.
So all we have to do is decompose the gravitational
force. We project that vector onto the r-hat
and theta-hat component vectors. In the r-hat
direction the magnitude is mg cos(theta) and
points outwards. In the theta-hat direction,
the magnitude is mg sin(theta) and points
in the negative theta-hat direction.
Newton's second law can now be written as
two component equations. For the radial
direction, we get this.
And in the tangential direction,
we get this.
This system of two equations has two unknowns.
The angle theta, and the tension.
Remember, that we are trying to find an expression for
how the angle theta depends on time. This
second equation is more useful to us, because
we can express both the angular velocity and
the angular acceleration in terms of theta.
Let's see how.
The circular motion of the pendulum is a 1-dimensional
motion, parameterized by time t.
The displacement of the pendulum away from center is the arc
length, which is L times theta. Because
the angular velocity is tangent to the circle
of motion, it can be found simply by differentiating
the displacement with respect to the parameter
t, which gives us that the angular velocity
is L times the time derivative of theta. The
angular acceleration is just the time derivative
of the angular velocity, and is given by L
times the second time derivative of theta.
Observe that this works because we are only
looking for the angular velocity and angular
acceleration which point tangent to our 1-dimensional
motion.
So now we've found expressions for the magnitudes
of the angular velocity and angular acceleration:
Here they are.
We can substitute these equations into Newton's
Second Law in the theta-hat direction; and we
obtain the following equation.
This is a second order ordinary differential
equation or 2nd order ODE.
It is ordinary because there is only one independent variable,
time, that the angle theta depends on. It
is second order because the highest degree
derivative that appears in the equation is
a second derivative.
Any function describing the pendulum motion
must satisfy this differential equation. Keep
in mind that there are other forces we ignored,
such as friction at the pivot point. This
is a very simple but nontrivial model for
the non-linear pendulum.
Notice that the first derivative term is our
velocity dependent drag force. If we decide
that this term is negligible, we would get
this equation.
It is still complicated, but you might notice that it looks somewhat familiar.
If we assume that the displacement of the
angle is very small, we can approximate sin
theta as the angle theta, which gives us this
equation.
This is the equation of the simple harmonic oscillator. So you see that this
piece connecting the term sin theta and the
second derivative of theta produces the oscillatory
behavior, and the first derivative term is
responsible for the damping of the motion.
We've seen that we can apply our knowledge
of physical laws to model a non-linear pendulum
with a differential equation.
How does this
differential equation describe the motion of a pendulum?
A differential equation is an equation where
the unknown element is a function, rather
than a number or a single value. The differential
equation is a rule that describes how the
system evolves from any time t to a time t
plus Delta t.
Where Delta t is a small time interval.
In particular, it describes the relationship between the angle theta and
its first and second derivatives as the system
evolves over time.
Remember that to describe the motion of the
pendulum, we need an expression for the angle
theta as a function of time. Do you think
there is a unique solution to this differential
equation? Pause the video here and discuss.
You probably have some sense that the motion
of the pendulum depends on how and where you
release it—conditions we refer to as initial
conditions.
For example, if we barely move the pendulum
away from center, and release it from rest,
the oscillation will be small. Larger displacements
will give larger oscillations, even though
eventually they all damp down to zero. All
of these pendulum motions satisfy the same
differential equation!
Since every starting position will give a
different dependence of theta on time, the
solution is not unique. We say that the solution
to a differential equation is an infinite
family of functions.
But what if we were are interested in finding
one solution in particular?
In the examples you just saw, we specified
the initial angle from which the pendulum
was released. Is this the only piece of information
we need to pick out a specific solution from
the infinite family?
Let's test that. Here you see two identical
pendulums, each starting from the same initial
angle. Are we guaranteed that the motion will
be the same?
Pause the video here to make a prediction.
Clearly not. What was the difference between
the initial conditions for these two pendulums?
The initial angles of both pendulums were
the same. However, one was released from rest,
and the other had an initial push. In other
words, the initial angular velocities were
different. Remember, our differential equation
only holds after the pendulum is released
because it doesn't include the action of the
pushing force.
Now we see the importance of specifying two
initial conditions—the initial angle and
the initial angular velocity. Remember, the
differential equation is the rule for how
the system evolves over time. In order to
solve this differential equation, we are going
to use the Taylor series expansion for the
function theta about t=0.
Recall that this is a polynomial series, whose
coefficients are determined by all of the
derivatives of the function theta at time
t=0. So how can we find all of these derivatives
of theta?
Let's use the differential equation to find
the second derivative at time t=0. Notice
that it depends on both of our initial conditions:
initial angle and initial angular velocity.
This is why we need those initial conditions.
We can differentiate the differential equation
to find the third derivative at time t=0.
Notice again that the third derivative depends
on the initial angle, the initial angular
velocity, and the second derivative at time
t=0.
We can continue this process and find recursive
formulas for the all of the higher order derivatives
of theta at time t=0! That's how the two initial
conditions allow us to pick out a solution,
by specifying all of the coefficients for
the Taylor series at t=0.
Our Taylor series solution completely describes the function
theta. But it only works on the interval of
convergence. If the series converges everywhere,
we're done! But if it doesn't converge everywhere,
it must converge on some interval.
A differential equation determines
a specific function if we have enough pieces
of initial data to determine all the Taylor
coefficients for the function. In our case,
with a second order ordinary differential
equation, we just needed two initial conditions.
Pause the video. If you had a third order
differential equation, how many initial conditions
would you need to specify one solution? Pause the video.
That's right, three!
We wanted to describe the motion of a pendulum.
We made a model, where we made
some simplifying assumptions then we applied Newton's
Second Law.
This gave us the differential equation, which
is the rule that angle theta
and its derivatives must satisfy.
We saw there is an infinite family of functions that solve our differential equation.
Because the differential equation was second
order, we needed 2 initial conditions to specify
one unique solution.
The initial conditions allowed us to determine
the coefficients of the Taylor series for
the angle theta as a function of time, which
solved the
differential equation.
I hope you found this video helpful in understanding differential equations.
Now we challenge you to model other systems using differential equations.